She's going home with me tonight.
[Music] Pretty sick.
That's a nice-looking car.
So never in my life have I sat in a car and
said, "I'm buying this car" until I met this
BMW i8.
This is the one from the movie Mission Impossible,
the one scene where Tom Cruz drives it and
everybody says, oh my gosh, is that like a
futuristic car?
It's known as one of the most futuristic cars
on the streets.
It looks like it's a 2025 car, the stuff we
used to watch in movies.
I couldn't believe it.
I drove it, we went in the streets, I took
corners, I was going 90 mph on a turn, and
it took it.
It sticks.
I'm blown away by that.
Went on the freeway, I hit 130 mph in no time,
zero to 60 roughly 4 second car.
And for an electric car to do that, it's very
impressive.
76 mile per gallon.
If you do it right, now obviously, I drive
sports, so I'm probably going to get 60 miles
per gallon, which is probably the biggest
miles per gallon I've ever had.
I've had an H2, which H2 gives you a sneeze
a gallon -- not an H2, an H1 -- Hummer H1.
I had a yellow H1.
So I ordered this because I just placed an
order on the 488 Ferrari and if you're part
of the Ferrari family, Ferrari is not like
Lamborghini.
We went to a Lamborghini dealership to order
a Huracan or an Aventador -- you could have
gotten it right there.
Ferrari, no way in the world, you can go buy
a brand spanking new Ferrari.
You've got to have it ordered or you've been
part of the family for a very long time.
So 488 is on its way.
This is the i8.
The story I want to tell you is, I remember
when, I'm the guy that you would get a $10
allowance, with a follow up statement saying,
hey, this is money, make sure you . . . and,
you know, it was always fear based, like we
were going to lose everything.
I grew up in a family that was very much scarcity.
There's a positive thing to it, and there's
a negative thing to it.
The positive thing to it is you're always
somewhat paranoid to make sure you know how
hard you're working for your money, but the
other part of it is that sometimes you don't
get a chance to enjoy what you're able to
buy.
My first car I bought an Expedition.
There's no way in the world I enjoyed it.
You know, when I bought my Mitsubishi Eclipse
in the Army, to me, that was a $5300 car with
Mitsubishi Eclipse, 1990, red, twin turbo,
it was my gosh, I can't believe I'm driving
a turbo Mitsubishi Eclipse.
But I was so nervous driving it, because I
didn't know how to make the payments, financial
issues, concerns, all of that, right?
And so, now, it's a complete different story.
I've owned many different cars, from Porsches
to you know, obviously Ferrari, you name it,
I've had it.
But it's great to know that you graduate to
the mindset of not being scared when you're
making a purchase, knowing where your situation
is.
You've always got to have a certain level
of paranoia because you don't want to just
go out there and splurge and buying everything
you're buying, but you got to make sure you
graduate that scarcity mindset or else, it
will just be tough to enjoy things in your
life.
And you can go a million miles an hour and
I'm as competitive as the next guy, but it's
good to be able to enjoy it.
So I said, "I like it."
We went to New Orleans, came back, when we
came back, Tom Ellsworth wanted to take care
of every detail right now with the car.
I came and picked it up after we went and
visited my school teachers for my kids, Tico
and Dylan, while my wife's at the office.
And my daughter's at the office with me, in
the morning after doing an incredible conference
call this morning with our leaders, Jason
and Matt.
It's just been a fascinating day.
But I tell you this one story.
A mentor once told me this.
I remember I was working with this one guy
and I said, "Hey man, what type of a house
do you live in?"
He said, "I live in a 10,000 square foot house."
I said, "Can you go show me your house?"
He said, "Oh, I can't.
"I said, "Why not?"
He said, it takes seven years to build it.
I'm like, man, this is a pretty intense house,
seven years to build.
I said, "What type of car do you drive?"
He said, "I've got a Ferrari."
I said, "Oh man, I'd love for you to take
me in your Ferrari."
He said, "Yeah, but it's special because Ferrari
is building it right now.
It's going to take about seven years for them
to build this Ferrari."
I'm like, man, this is like insane.
A Ferrari that takes seven years.
. . Yeah, a limited edition, just for me.
I'm like, that's unbelievable.
I said you've got a private jet?
Yeah, I've got a private jet.
I said, "Can you take me in your private jet?"
He said, "It's a very limited edition private
yet, it takes 15 years for them to build this
private jet for me."
So I was an naive entrepreneur.
I didn't know where this guy was going with
it until he finally explained it to me.
He said, "Look, you in your mind keep imagining
that 10,000 square foot house.
You in your mind keep imagining driving that
Ferrari.
You take seven years to bust your butt and
you can have whatever you want as an entrepreneur."
And he was absolutely right, because all I
did was put my head down and just get to work
and next thing you know, all those things
become a reality.
So my message to you, is next time someone
asks you what kind of a car you drive, you
know what I want you to tell them?
I want you to say, "I drive a Ferrari."
Oh no way!
Oh yeah, yeah.
Can I see it?
Yeah, Ferrari is right now building it, it's
going to take about seven years for them to
build it.
Oh, what kind of a house do you got?
I got about a 13,000 square foot house.
Man, that's insane, can I come and visit your
house?
It's still being built.
It takes about seven years.
You got a jet?
Yeah, it's being built, 15 years.
And see the reaction, then explain, and go
work your butt off and have those things become
a reality.
This will not be the last car I buy.
I'm a capitalist.
I appreciate good engineering.
I love the details in this car, with the blue
on the outside and the inside and the seat
belts and the speed and the technology and
the way it controls when you brake, it creates
more electricity.
Now you get a chance to park it in places
where for electric cars and get a charge.
And in my building it's perfect because the
best parking spot in our building is an electrical
car parking spot that's free from the building
and I get to park it there in front of the
elevator, which is boom.
I just go upstairs.
So that was a part of buying the car as well.
But I wanted to make sure that you understand
this, too.
As you're watching this video, keep in mind,
this is more about you than it is about me.
You and I may never meet each other, ever.
You and I may never have an interaction one-on-one.
But you may be watching this on Valuetainment
as a fan of the content, and having your own
dreams.
So the goal is for you to get to the point
where you no longer look to the right side
of the menu because it doesn't freak you out.
The goal is to get to the point where you're
no longer worried about the price tag because
you can afford it.
The goal is to get to that point where you
can do the things you want to do without losing
sleep over it or arguing with your wife, with
your husband, with your family, with your
parents, and more importantly, with yourself.
Because that scarcity mindset is fine to have
to allow you to get to the point that you
want to be, but if you're there all the time,
it's going to be very difficult for you to
enjoy life.
Anyways, hey, for all of you that are helping
us get to 100K subs, and you guys saw the
video last week, Good Voice, Bad Voice, we
almost didn't launch that video.
That was a video I was holding back to launching
it, but I'm glad that we did.
If you haven't subbed, please do so, and if
you're watching this video on any other website,
you can always go to PatrickBetDavid.com give
me the ring tone, boom.
Magic in the i8, and you can always get a
ton of content on Patrick Bet-David.com.
Thanks everybody, take care, bye bye.